[MUSIC PLAYING]
- So our next session
is on ASL signing.
And it will be
chaired and introduced
by Professor Amy
Szarkowski who is
a professor in the Department
of Psychiatry at Harvard Medical
School, and a psychologist
who specializes
in working with children who
are deaf or hard of hearing
and their families.
So, Professor Szarkowski?
Amy?
Where are you?
Oh, yes, great.
Thank you.
- You guys ready?
We're going to take a change
in topic at this moment.
We're still under the
umbrella of communication,
but now, a different
way of communicating
with sign language.
We have two fabulous
presenters with us today.
One of our presenters identifies
as deaf, as a performer.
And second, we have a
sign language interpreter.
Both these ladies are
brilliant and we're
thrilled to have them here
and share their perspectives.
And that perspective
is going to be
about how sign language
in that communication
impacts interactions,
specifically pertaining
to beauty and gender.
You guys ready?
All right, let's go.
[APPLAUSE]
- Well you guys can see I am
a female with a male voice.
Right here we have
a male interpreter,
so I hope you guys
can kind of just
reconcile that with the
appearance versus the voice.
But I think that it would
be a great actual match
for this topic on gender.
ASL, the acronym for
American Sign Language.
This language is complex,
rich, it is full of history.
This linguistic,
beautiful language
is something that I've had--
and it's been part of American
culture for over 200 years.
It has been down since
back in native times
and has transitioned
as a language,
like many languages do,
over a 200 year period.
Now there are formal
language systems, as we know,
and how language develops
is by the culture,
the community, sharing
knowledge, experiences.
And therefore
emerges further uses
of language, language
choices, and signs,
and those are based on
culture that were predating
those currently using it.
American Sign Language has five
distinct and unique parameters.
I'm going to show you these
to help you understand
how we communicate and
how it has developed
using a cultural framework.
The first is hand shape.
So, obviously,
for sign language,
you need a hand shape
like this or this.
[LAUGHTER]
So that is the
shape of your hand--
it is very crucial.
Now, which hand shape you use
really is dependent on context.
Second parameter is location.
Where is that hand going to?
Now there are various
categories within that.
As an example, you
can start up here
in this location, versus this
location, versus this location,
versus here, versus out here.
All the signs that
we'll be doing--
and you'll see-- have
that specific objection.
Objective in using that
location about what it's
going to indicate, and
the various categories
and what it means.
The next parameter is movement.
So remember we have the hand
shape, we have a location,
and now we're going to
put some movement to it.
[LAUGHTER]
Now what does this mean?
Hello?
Right?
So there's where movement
is the characteristic
within the language--
that parameter.
Now what about this?
What does this mean?
- Stop.
- That means stop, right?
Or, whoa.
Hold on.
Or you can be welcoming someone.
So again, movement is
such a crucial aspect
of language in its expression.
So the next parameter
is palm orientation.
As I just demonstrated
as an example,
using this hand shape,
which would mean, hey, wait,
versus this, changing
my palm orientation,
could say you, or
only you, or wait.
It's the same movement, but
the palm orientation now
indicates a different
meaning in the language.
So again, palm
orientation is crucial.
And finally, but last but not
least, is facial expressions.
This is how you communicate
feelings, thoughts--
also gives a sense of time.
Also, as an example, using this.
This is an example of
indicating someone walking.
[LAUGHTER]
You get the picture.
This is a long walk.
Someone's going to be dragging.
So simply by that
facial expression,
we've been able to evoke
if someone is having
a good day, or a bad day.
So all those are parameters
that are so crucial.
And by the selection
of those parameters,
can then craft your message
and convey your culture,
your personality, your tone.
So now I'm going
to go back to one
of those parameters
about location.
These two are very unique along
with these other few locations
associated with gender.
It's associated with
male and female.
Gender has already been
assigned to those locations.
Male is here.
Any male oriented sign is
typically in this location.
But why do you think up here?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
- Any guesses?
- The brain, the
head, intellect.
What else what else you got?
- Hats.
OK.
Yeah.
So back in time where
gentlemen were wearing hats.
Showing someone is a thinker,
as opposed to being emotive.
Logic, intellect,
and, of course,
going on with those
other adjectives.
But again, that
orientation, that location.
Now female.
Any guesses what
location that would be?
Let me see.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
- Oh, interesting.
I see a few.
Nice, that's interesting.
Why did you guys pick this as a
location I saw in the audience?
Emotion, love,
nurturer, caregiver.
It's actually this
location right here.
This is the location for female.
So again, female oriented
signs of that love,
emotion, nurturing, typically
have these two locations.
But primarily on the chin here.
So there are subsets within just
the idea of location, which is,
of course, indicating binary.
You have boy, as girl,
because the bonnet.
Boys because of
the baseball cap.
So this is the sign for girl.
So this is the kind of
the language we use.
So I'm going to give
you guys-- we're
going to do a little
hands-on activity.
So we're going to
pick a hand shape.
Let's do this hand
shape right here.
So I want everyone to copy
me, you in the audience.
We're going to give
you a movement.
Now the term is going to be mom.
Where do you think that hand
shape movement should go?
Show me.
Like this?
Perfect.
Now, for the term
dad, where do you
think that hand shape
would go as far as location
is concerned?
Here?
Exactly.
Great job.
So, similar hand shape, similar
movement, different location.
There demonstrating
the role of father
versus mother, boy
versus girl, grandparents
or grandpa, grandma.
What about Grandpa?
What do you think?
[LAUGHTER]
Oh, wow yeah.
Right off the bat.
And this would be
grandmother, or grandma.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
- Notice that movement
in that location.
So that is a systematic way in
American Sign Language using
that movement and location.
So now, in a generation,
fast-forwarding to now,
where we have the spectrum
of male and female
that we're looking at, how
does this impact sign language
and how it's expressed,
where things are not
already assigned?
So as a deaf community,
this is something
we're starting to look at.
What is a sign to
identify a gender?
And other signs that we
might not have signs for,
that have not yet
been established.
So, for example, the
term transgender.
The sign is this.
And notice that location.
Why do you think this
location was used?
It's there to indicate the soul.
The inner workings of
someone's heart, their soul.
All the rest is a shell.
Everything else that's
been biologically assigned,
but to a person's soul.
And so, when they have
that transformation,
that's where that movement
comes in that location.
A beautiful sign.
Now the hand shape.
Like this.
That hand shape, along
with that movement,
has a very unique
theme, a distinct theme.
Now the sign for
beautiful is this.
Notice that hand shape
and that movement?
You can sign grow.
Also a part of that
same sign, culture.
So that hand shape in itself
has a very rich history,
and such deep
meaning and context.
So, to use that sign and
assign it to who I am,
how do I identify.
And that's where the origin
for transgender, and that
sign in our community.
Another term-- non-binary.
We've heard that today.
From a hearing,
non-signing perspective,
you have the words
male, female, binary.
Those systems have
been in place.
And those who are
nonconforming, that's
where we come up
with the word non,
to then show the contrast of
that standard nonconformity.
Non-binary-- to disassociate
from that concept
of the standard stereotype,
or that established systematic
terminology.
And again, in time, there
will be new identities
that will continue to come up.
But the first step and
stage is to disassociate
from the norm in those
cultural words and labels
as we know them.
And that is also impacting
American Sign Language.
There are things that we
might not have a sign--
and there are various rules,
grammatical, linguistic rules,
that are associated
to sign language.
Remember, you have
to have a location.
Now think about this neutral
space right here as a location.
As you can see, it's
disassociated from my body.
So, as an example,
you have non-binary,
or, just for short,
the acronym NB,
as in American Sign Language,
we'll just use that short.
But out in space, as you can
see, is a different location.
So this is something that's
continuing to evolve.
As we saw hats and bonnets
and various fashion items
that we've just
talked about have
changed till today, we also have
that same thing with language
and it's a beautiful
thing to see.
We have one other activity
before I'm out of my time here.
I'm going to give you
another hand shape.
Do this as your hand shape.
This could represent an
individual or a person.
That's what that represents.
Now, if someone was
going to indicate
that that individual
was walking, how would
you do that movement?
Like this, or like this.
Now, how would you
demonstrate or manifest
that person as masculine
with that same hand
shape and movement?
What would you do?
[LAUGHTER]
Ha.
You wouldn't do it by your
head, because that actually
would mean you're
walking on the head.
Be careful with the location.
Location, location
is everything.
So how would you express
and demonstrate masculinity?
How would you do it?
[LAUGHTER]
Well you're kind of cheating
doing two hands at once there.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
So you're adding those
facial expressions,
those non-manual markers.
[LAUGHTER]
You see how crucial it was
to identify that person
and how they identify?
[LAUGHTER]
Now what about a female?
In a feminine way,
how would you do that?
[LAUGHTER]
Same sign, same hand shape,
show me what you got.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[LAUGHTER]
- See the difference?
So again, back to those
fundamental parameters.
This is what I live
and breathe in my work
as a performer and an artist.
How I can manipulate
these parameters,
those hand shapes, movement,
location, orientation,
and facial expressions, to
express who I am as a person.
Again, expressing my world view,
my political view, my belief
system, my culture, all in one.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Before we get on
to my presentation,
I just want to share
a few disclaimers.
For this, I will be using
American Sign Language
and English, but I
want to recognize
that that has an inherent
privilege for the language I
choose to use.
For this presentation
and its perspective,
I will be using the terms
female as a umbrella term.
So, I mean all of
those who identify.
So I want to recognize as a
white woman how society views
me, how society views
women, and women of color,
and that discrepancy.
So just as a whole,
to keep that in mind.
Also, I want to clarify
some terminology
that I might be using.
I will state the word
deaf, which is an umbrella
term because it is a very
diverse cultural community,
and they all use
American Sign Language.
So that can indicate someone
who is deaf, deaf-blind, someone
who is hard of hearing.
But again, that language
that they're using
is American Sign Language.
But to interact
in the world, they
may need to use an interpreter
for someone who does not sign.
Also I might speak about
male, and female, transgender
as well, and cisgender.
And I have two
scenarios and anecdotes
to show what it looks like
as an American Sign Language
interpreter, whether it's in
public or behind closed doors.
Here's the scenario.
As a staff interpreter,
I was working
at Boston Children's Hospital.
There was an appointment,
which I went in.
The provider and the doctor was
there speaking to the patient.
This is post-op.
And then was saying, hey,
you gotta get off your butt--
and the doctor, as he said
that, he smacked me in my butt.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
- Fact.
This recent Super
Bowl, if you saw,
there was a press
conference where
Mayor Walsh-- and I was there
on stage interpreting with him.
And that was very public.
And it was edited where
someone grabbed a clip
and put it online, on
reddit, and people were then
started making various
comments about my look,
my sexual performance,
what I looked like.
The commentary went on and on.
It was a free-for-all.
But those were two examples
of me just as I am--
Jackie.
But it's not alone.
I'm not unique in
that one experience.
So it's interesting
with this topic today,
and how we see women, and
how it impacts deaf men,
and how it impacts deaf
youth who are boys.
And that's what I want
to share with you guys.
- So what was that like for you?
Listening to me in
a conventionally
accepted male voice, versus
now listening to me in my own?
How does that difference
shape your judgments about me?
About your willingness
to trust me, to hire me?
I intentionally did not
ask you if that difference
had an impact.
For today, I want us to
examine that dynamic--
when deaf boys and
men are working
with female interpreters,
American Sign Language
interpreters.
And I want to challenge you to
examine your implicit biases
and assess how, just as it
says here on the screen,
how and to what degree that
experience of listening
to a deaf man through
a female's voice
is impacting your actions, and
what is your responsibility
to make that connection
more authentic?
So why does this matter?
In 2016, a researcher
by the name of Punch,
in her review of
literature, found
that deaf people
were nearly two times
as likely to be unemployed or
underemployed when compared
to non-deaf individuals.
And yet, when it
comes to one's career,
a 2015 report from the Federal
Reserve Bank of New York
put it bluntly.
They said that your first
10 years in the labor market
are likely to shape your entire
lifetime earning potential.
So it's not
far-fetched to believe
that because of society's
treatment of women,
combined with the fact that 86%
of the people doing this work
identify as female, is having
an impact on deaf men and boys
and their social mobility--
their lifetime earning
potential.
And so that is the space
I want to invite you
into today to explore.
I have a few studies
to share to help
illuminate further
why this topic is
worth our consideration.
As I share these,
I want you to think
about listening to a deaf man
through a female interpreter's
voice.
In 2012, Karpowitz,
Mendelberg, and Shaker
showed us that holding the
floor for a greater percentage
of a group's
deliberation made you
more likely to be seen as
influential in the group.
However, if you were a
woman interrupting a man,
you were likely to be
seen as disrespectful,
whereas a man
interrupting a woman
was seen as more assertive.
In a meta-analysis
of previous studies,
Williams and Tiedens
in 2015 found
that women who
assertively emphasized
their skills, accomplishments,
or desire to lead,
tended to be liked less and
to be seen as less hireable,
compared to men describing
themselves identically.
Specific to the work of
female ASL interpreters,
Colleen Jones, in her
2017 graduate thesis work,
found that non-deaf men who
were listening to deaf men
through a female's
interpretation
rated him as less intelligent
and less trustworthy as
compared to
listening to deaf men
through male
interpreters voices.
And last, a 2018 study from
ASL interpreter Lena Jenny
looked into
genderqueer and female
presenting interpreters with
masculine tethered traits.
And she found that
if you are masculine
presenting and utilize
masculine discourse traits,
you may actually be compounding
the discrimination faced
by these deaf men.
So let's see if we
have this so far.
If we're masculine
presenting, we
need to try to
sound more feminine.
But if we're
feminine presenting,
we need to try to
sound more masculine.
All women should probably
try to sound more masculine
when other men are listening.
But don't interrupt men.
Right?
[LAUGHTER]
Got it.
When it's all women, we can
sound authoritative, but not
tout our accomplishments.
And when men are listening, or
when we're in mixed company,
we need to tone it down, but
be ready to celebrate ourselves
in a moment's notice.
[LAUGHTER]
Got it.
So, because we are
damned if we do,
and damned if we don't,
as was just shown,
many female interpreters
report using
any of the following
compensatory strategies.
We stand taller,
we lower our voices
during the interpretation,
we dress in neutral attire
that we think is
more androgynous.
Although I just learned
in the last presentation
it's actually more
masculine, which is really
screwing with my mind.
Thank you.
We maintain distant
attitudes, we
learn to interrupt
to claim the floor,
and we train
ourselves to eliminate
what is conventionally
known as powerless language.
Folks, we do all of
this while navigating
one of the most cognitively
complex tasks out there.
This is the world
of ASL interpreting,
through the lens of a
female ASL interpreter.
I want to take a step back.
So we just covered a
little bit about what
female interpreters
are up against,
but I want you to
understand what you--
I want to know what
your experience is.
When you hire an ASL
interpreter, what's that like?
We'll take a broad
stroke here, just
so we can appreciate
where the daily reality
of deaf men and female ASL
interpreters is situated.
ASL interpreting as
a profession was not
known in the United
States until 1964,
which is when our
National Professional
Organization, the Registry
of Interpreters for the Deaf,
was established.
We are predominantly female.
As was mentioned,
86% of RID members
who chose to identify
a gender are female.
We are overwhelmingly white.
87% of us doing this
work identify as white.
And this is why you'll see
in my presentation today,
the majority of my photos
are of white professionals.
Because that's the reality
that we're up against--
that folks are dealing
with-- even though we are not
representative of the
increasingly diverse
populations of whom we serve.
At least 93% of our members
are second or other language
learners of American
Sign Language.
OK.
So that's the larger context.
We're a young profession,
we are predominantly female
white women, and we have
come into the language
in the community as guests,
or second and other language
learners of ASL, present
company included.
Now that you have a
sense of who we are,
I want to look at some of the
commonly reported experiences
of this predominately
female workforce
when working with men.
Deaf and non-deaf men alike
routinely apologize to us
when they drop f-bombs.
[LAUGHTER]
Now, when men are
with other men,
we know that they swear to
decrease social distance,
for social power.
So if they're censoring their
speech because of our presence,
how does that impact
their interaction
and its authenticity?
Now, this happens in
one-on-one interactions.
It also happens in larger
all-male only spaces.
The entire dynamic will shift
if I, or any of my sister
interpreters, walk into
a fraternity event,
or an all-male sex offender
group therapy session,
or a deaf man
wanting to find out
what's up with his male doctor.
Right?
So, considering the reality
that less than 14% of my field
identifies as male, what
other strategies can we,
and you who work
with us, what can you
do to level the playing field?
All right.
Picture this.
You're a college
student, you're enrolled
in one of the interpreting
programs in the United States,
and your college announces
that a very well-known comedian
is coming to campus.
Interpreters will be provided.
So naturally, you
buy tickets, right?
You want to see a
real-life interpretation,
you want to hone your
understanding of ASL,
and dream about one day being
hired as a professional sign
language interpreter.
OK.
So the show starts,
and at some point
the comedian suddenly takes
notice of the female ASL
interpreter working.
In fact, you might have
seen these clips on YouTube.
He tries to get a
rise out of her.
He starts using obscene
language that I will not
use today out of respect
for my colleague working.
But the interpreter
maintains her composure,
interpreting every single jab
that comes at her expense.
And you can't help but think,
sitting there in the audience,
is this what you're aspiring
to be when you grow up?
Exploited for a cheap laugh and
used in public, or anywhere?
This situation is not unique to
that individual I just shared.
It's one that many of us
have found ourselves in.
Consider the reddit example
that I mentioned earlier.
It turns out,
though, that it's not
just the ignorant public who
sexualized female interpreters.
In 2008, a video relay
service provider,
one of the largest employers
of interpreters nationwide,
denied its female
interpreters, its employees,
the option of disconnecting
from a serial predator
who would connect with
them on the webcam,
not to place a phone call, but
to masturbate in front of them.
Again, it's not
just sexual interest
from deaf and
non-deaf individuals.
It's that female interpreters
are packaged as a commodity
and disregarded
by-- even our own--
by those who employ us and
who supposedly have our backs.
What I find myself
wondering about though,
in these incidents and others,
is the lack of accountability.
These non-deaf people,
intentionally or not,
are disrespecting an entire
population with their quips.
There are deaf
patrons wanting to see
the show, deaf people at
home watching the press
conference about the
upcoming snowstorm,
wanting to know what's going on.
Or a deaf man going to the
doctor, wanting to know what's
wrong with him, all of these
without drawing undue attention
to the fact that their
communications with you
are mediated through a female.
For this next section, I'd like
to borrow from the LifeCourse
Framework in the field
of public health.
And if this is
unfamiliar to you,
the basic premise is that all
factors, genetics, nutrition,
social relationships,
financial security, exposure
to environmental toxins
and the like, all of these
have a cumulative
impact on one's health
throughout their lifetime.
And so, what we
experience today as
chronic physical and
mental conditions have
root causes that date way back.
Now, if we take that
LifeCourse Framework
and apply it to the
life of a deaf male,
for whom communication
with non-deaf individuals,
as we've discussed
time and again,
is mediated through a
female ASL interpreter.
I want to know, what's
the cumulative impact,
and can we even name it?
Please note that the following
list is not exhaustive, nor is
it true for everyone.
Interpreters are not
employed in all situations
or to the same degree.
I'm simply using
these as exemplars.
Let's start with a
deaf boy's childhood.
Consider his education
and his extracurriculars.
Please also note, that 87% of
deaf children in the United
States are not sent to schools
with deaf peers, deaf role
models, and others who are like
them, in a visually accessible
educational environment.
Instead they're sent to
schools with peers and adults
who are not like them, and their
entire educational experience
is mediated through a likely
white female interpreter.
So these are the public
schools that they're in.
So think about it.
Your classroom activities, your
group work with peers, maybe
even your social
connections with peers,
all mediated through an adult
woman as a young deaf boy.
But it's not just about the
boys lived experience or other's
experience of him.
How does the presence
of an adult woman
impact him in ways that we
might not even be able to name?
That's what I want to know.
Let's look at adolescence.
Let's take some
common experiences.
Driver's Ed, internship
interviews or placements,
meetings with
guidance counselors
to talk about your future plans,
athletics, if that's your bag.
How is an adolescent
boy's experience
shaped by working
with an adult female
for these rites of passage?
What about how others treat him?
What opportunities he's offered?
What he learns about
his changing body,
about networking,
or getting ahead
in love, life, and his career?
As a young adult, what
are the social, financial,
and academic impacts of having
a female in your college classes
or in your vocational training?
Or in Greek life?
Right?
All you want to do is make a
solid impression as a pledge,
or shoot the shit with
your fraternity brothers,
and then here's this
woman in the middle of it
all who very well may
be your parents age.
Look, I'm not saying these
poor deaf guys-- right--
they have to work with us.
And I'm certainly
not saying deaf men
and female ASL interpreters
shouldn't be working together.
I'm just arguing that
society's view of women
has short-term and long-term
impacts on these deaf boys
and these men and their
lifetime earning potential,
their social mobility, and
perhaps even their health.
Lastly, for social services
and health care, many of us
can agree that we feel
more comfortable when
we're working with a
health care provider who
shares our same gender.
Deaf men are not afforded
this luxury though.
It is more than likely
that at some point
they will have a female present
for their consultations,
or for other health care
encounters that many of us
can agree we'd rather not have
someone of the opposite gender
in.
OK.
And so here we are.
All I have for you is questions.
[LAUGHTER]
And what I want from you is
introspection and a willingness
to own what's yours to own.
If we buy that
non-deaf people often
see us interpreters as
extensions of deaf people,
then how you see me as a female
may be helping or hindering
someone else's social
mobility, maybe
without you even realizing it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Yes.
OK.
So, my first comment
is for Rosa Lee.
First of all, you should know
that Rosa Lee has the Rosa Lee
Show.
And you should also
know that there
are a whole bunch
of videos online
of Rosa Lee doing
signed interpretation
of various songs.
They're amazing, check them out.
Rosa Lee.
- Thank you.
Thank you for that comment.
- Yes.
When you're in
situations where there's
mixed deaf and hearing groups
how do you claim your space?
- In what context, if I may?
So, space relating to--
if you mind, give me an example?
- Yeah.
If it's a mixed group, there are
some individuals who are deaf,
some who are hearing,
some who are male,
some who are
female, how do you--
when you really want
to make a point--
how do you make sure that you
have the ground to communicate?
- Well, in my work as
an artist, my space,
my pallet is the stage.
So using the platform in
itself, that is my space
and where I can express myself--
up here on stage.
So allowing myself to
play along that spectrum,
again it could be politically
related, personally
related, a narrative or
an anecdote, world view.
So using that space,
I'm able to control
the dialogue and the flow of
communication and information.
- OK.
Jackie, question for you.
Last month I had the
opportunity to present
at a conference
of superintendents
of schools for the deaf.
One of those
individuals was male.
And when he followed up to see
who the interpreters would be
and the conference had hired
two female interpreters,
he demanded that a male
interpreter be hired.
And it became part of
the political discourse.
He made the argument that
it was important for him
that his voice be
perceived in a way
that he felt
represented who he was.
I just wonder if you
could reflect on that.
I think it's very much
related to your talk.
If you were to give advice
to others in that situation
or something.
How would-- what might
you respond to that?
- Sorry, I'm just having that
internal debate about which
language to choose again.
How to respond.
I think I wholeheartedly
support that decision.
And in fact, in my work,
predominately with women--
other female interpreters--
and on the rare occasion--
which by the way folks,
the fact that there
are two male interpreters as
part of the interpreting team
is really screwing up
everything I just told you.
[LAUGHTER]
I have nothing but respect
for my colleagues working.
I appreciate them giving
their time today and, dammit--
the truth is, though, that
more than likely you're
going to be working with
female interpreters.
But on the rare occasion when
I do have a male colleague
and we're at an event
where there is a deaf male,
there have been
times in the past
where we have intentionally
assigned the male interpreter
to make sure that he is always
interpreting into English when
that deaf man says anything.
Because, based on experience,
it's harder to claim the floor.
It's harder to
interrupt with my voice.
People don't give
that deaf man--
regardless of his
position in the company--
which is interesting-- they
don't give him the space.
So your question to Rosa
Lee about taking up space--
a man's voice.
Honestly.
And so-- it's true.
It's very true.
So-- oh yeah, please.
- Yeah, if I could
piggyback on that.
Marlee Matlin, you guys know the
well-known actress who's deaf,
she always has a male
interpreter with her.
The reason is to remind people
that I am my own person.
I'm my own individual.
So sometimes you'll be
looking at her, Marlee,
and interacting with her,
but you have that male voice.
And sometimes, if she's working
with a female interpreter,
then that kind of
blurs the line.
And then they start
focusing and interacting
with the interpreter
and thinking
about the interpreting
process, and, oh,
look at that beautiful
language, as opposed to actually
interacting with her directly.
So she's always made sure
to have a male interpreter
work alongside her.
So again, based on
context, whether it's
a presentation formally
in an academic setting
or what have you.
- A friend who's
deaf was telling me
about other deaf
professionals she
knows who are men who
will, intentionally,
when they travel, request
female interpreters
to screw with the
audience and jar the ear.
Right?
So you can manipulate it
in that way and use us--
whatever your goals are--
to accomplish.
I think.
- From the perspective of
both an individual who is deaf
and an individual who
does interpretation,
I wonder what your
thoughts are about ways
that we need to infuse
training to help interpreters
to become more aware of this?
And to help deaf individuals to
become more aware of how they
might request interpretation?
- OK.
So see, that's my problem.
Right?
Because if you look
anywhere in the literature,
if you look at how we train
interpreters, especially
female interpreters,
it's, how can you
be more assertive and more
dominant to take up the space
so that you can
placate the society
and let it continue
running status quo?
My question to you all, as
majority non-signing folks,
is, what is your
responsibility in that?
Right?
So I'm just going to
deflect that question
right back to you.
We are training female
ASL interpreters
to do all of the things
that I just said and more.
And I won't talk about what
we should be encouraging
the deaf community to
do, but my call to you
all is be a part of
that process too.
Right?
If you're hiring an interpreter
to interpret an interview
for an employee coming in,
or whatever ways you're
interacting with us, be
a part of that process.
Find out who the interpreters
are ahead of time, set up time
to meet with them in advance,
check in with the deaf folks,
make sure that they are
satisfied with the services.
All of that.
I think everybody has to
be present in that process
and stop pretending
that we can just
blend into any sort of situation
and pick up right where you've
left off, even though
we're there for a day.
We're there for an interview.
We're there for just
a snapshot in time.
We need to you to
take the lead on that.
[LAUGHTER]
Please and thank you.
- Amen.
I can just add a amen to that.
- Yeah.
I'm curious, Rosa Lee,
about the added demands
that you see being placed
on you in situations
like those interviews or
situations where you're
interacting with individuals who
are not familiar with deafness
or deaf culture.
Where do you see the
responsibility being
yours to educate, and where
do you see the line between it
really isn't you're
responsibility?
- For thoughts on that,
I think it would really
depend on the environment.
When you're dealing in
a personal situation
where it is a
medical appointment,
I think it's medical
related, medical issues.
I want to focus on that
information as opposed
to being an educator
in role at that time.
I'm a patient.
So for the patient
to then explain, oh,
this is the role
of the interpreter,
of you as a doctor.
No.
You know, as opposed to,
in a different environment
or context, as an example,
like a IEP meeting.
So in a K through
12 situation where
there might be an
opportunity there to explain
about the communication roles.
And again, the objective is to
get the results that I want.
So I have to kind
of walk that line.
Again, just, what
the overall objective
is in working and
interacting with me.
So sometimes it's an
educational roles,
sometimes an advocate
role, sometimes it's
me to step back and just be me.
So it's like, hey, that's
your job, not mine.
- Great.
In line with Jackie's
comment around what can we
do to be active
around that, I do
want to applaud Radcliffe
for inviting ASL interpreters
and having interpretation
at a lot of their events.
And to reiterate,
both to Radcliffe,
and then, any others
who are planning events,
that when you have that
available, it really does
increase the
likelihood, both of that
deaf individuals can come--
sometimes people say, well
nobody's asked us for it.
But they might not know
that that's a possibility.
So by arranging that and making
communication accessible,
I think that's a
very important thing
that we can do to be proactive.
And it also increases
visibility, and awareness,
and access in ways that
are really important.
With that, I'm going to
open it up for questions.
As others have
said, please join us
in the center to ask a question
and our speakers will respond.
- Thank you so much for
helping me understand
the way that gender is
based on location in so much
of the signs.
But I'm curious about the way
that gender accidentally works
its way into speech and sign.
In the way that, kind of,
declarative statements
tend to be read as more a
kind of a male speech pattern,
and interrogative
statements tend
to be read as more of a
female speech pattern.
I'm wondering, what
are the accidental tics
inside a sign that could
show unintentional ways that
gender has kind of
woven its way into sign?
- It's going to get another
interpretation of that
because that is a
deep concept for sure.
Jackie?
[LAUGHTER]
- So one example,
and please, Rosa Lee,
correct me if I'm wrong.
So the sign as we talked about
mother or father, mom or dad,
but now in the LGBTQ community,
any of non-binary individuals.
So it's like mom, mom so
it's kind of like, all right,
how are we going to sign that?
Dad, dad, or in the
middle of those two
established locations?
So just as an example like that
that has that attributed to it.
So, parents is signed like this.
So if you had two
moms, then it's like,
are you going to not go
up to the higher location
for that sign that
is indicating parent?
So also in this region
here, around your nose,
it's typically negative.
Something that is
lousy, smells, stinks.
Actually this is
a sign for penis,
since we were on that
topic today earlier.
[LAUGHTER]
Just the nose.
All right.
Well, just, anyways, it's
not really a positive place.
So it's just kind of
maybe around this region
or this location.
So there has been some
discourse as far as
whether that is a positive
or negative attribute
of that location.
But again, it's something that
is very fluid and evolving.
And over time, we will
get to the right sign.
So, definitely.
- And if I could add just from
an interpreter perspective.
I-- I'm sorry?
That's OK.
- Just one moment
for the interpreter.
Thanks.
- I have one perspective
from the interpreting world.
So in ASL, pronominalization
is gender neutral.
And so, when you're an
interpreter working with a deaf
individual who's referring
to someone in space,
but they haven't told
you their gender--
they haven't told you
anything about them--
you as the interpreter then
have to make that decision.
There are so many different
strategies we use.
Sometimes we get our foot
caught in our mouths,
where we assign a gender
to someone who we think,
and then we end up having
to backtrack and own
that error as well.
But, specific to the language,
that shows up in our work
as well.
- One interesting thing
about American Sign Language
is this right here, this
indication using as pronoun
is actually very neutral,
which works for an interpreter,
as Jackie just mentioned.
And I could sign this and
be like, it was he, or she,
or this person told me,
or this person told me.
So that's one example of
that neutral language.
And that's more work
for you, Jackie.
Sorry.
Does that answer your question?
- It's a little bit different.
But it's OK--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
- I guess what I mean
is, could you show us
the difference between the way
a man might sign something that
shows more power
in the situation?
But it's not about the
words they're using,
it's about the way
the sign looks.
With more certainty,
versus with more, kind of,
you know, questioning.
Or lack of confidence
or something.
Could you show us
the way that gender
might be embodied in
a particular sign that
might show the difference
between the way power
is encoded into the performance
of a particular sign?
- I would say with facial
expressions is probably
the parameter I would refer to.
Eye gaze and glance.
Like this, where your
eyes are looking downward.
The use of hands
like this that is
indicating a status or class.
Or as opposed to doing
this, ask her, or he.
So again, that could then refer
again to a status in class.
So location that way is
one way of indicating that.
So there is a way
of inferring it.
So there's a lot of -ists.
Oddist attitude,
racist attitude,
whatever the case may be
within the diverse community.
As it is in society,
as diverse as it
is to indicate that status,
just by that range of height
and location.
Also assign, also
being conveyed--
very small signing space or a
large signing space, like this.
So those are other
ways within, again,
how you morph along
those parameters.
And slight changes can
indicate that power and control
and status as an example.
Does that work for you?
All right.
Great.
- Next question please.
- So interesting.
I had a question about
the idea of seeing women
in positions of authority and
is there a corollary view?
I understand the idea of
the gendered interpretation
upon males, for instance,
having a female signer,
and that sexist interpretation
that's coming from the hearing
community.
But is there a corollary
impact of boys growing up
seeing women in
authoritative positions
that actually empowers a kind
of more equal gender dynamic
within the deaf community?
[LAUGHTER]
- That's a new research
project for Jackie to take on.
[LAUGHTER]
That is a great, great question.
- So maybe I would
then counter that
and say, is the societal
view of sexist perspective,
is that paralleled in
the deaf community?
And I would say
that it is the same.
So there is a -ist-- a sexist.
So if you have that,
it doesn't really
matter if the person
is deaf or hearing,
whether that is impacted
in that dynamic.
Because the person is female,
or identifies as female, and is
Caucasian.
Would that make
them less sexist?
I don't know.
That could be a great
research topic though.
- I can add, just from a
developmental psychology
perspective, that the idea for
young boys, elementary age,
for example, the way that
they connect with teachers
and paraprofessionals,
looking up to them
and feeling that connection
with their teacher.
But we definitely see--
in a clinical view--
adolescents, middle
school, high schoolers,
who then have to rely on that.
They think it is a
very different kind
of a relationship.
So in part, it might be, here's
another nurturing person who
is involved in your
life, which can be great,
and a resistance to feeling--
to needing that later on.
- Thank you.
- Mm-hmm.
Yes.
We need voice
interpretation please.
- Oh I'm just asking you to come
up here so everyone can see.
- Hi guys.
I'm just going to kind
of throw this out there.
So an event where you have, as
an example, Martin Luther King.
There is an event with MLK Day.
And then you have
an individual who's
assigned as the interpreter.
How are they going
to handle that where
they're white, female, as
opposed to being someone
who is a person of color?
Now, how does that go as
far as the perspective
of assigning that person?
Is there an option?
And which one would you pick,
and which one should I pick?
Should it be the person who is
of color, just because they're
of color?
Just kind of throw
that out there.
And you might not
have a response,
but it might come down
to resource availability.
So just a thought about that?
- I would say that in the
industry of interpreting
as a profession,
it's been terrible--
to be quite honest-- with
interpreters of color.
And sometimes to say, hey, we
want to grow that population
and that demographic.
But to really
actually proactively
go out to that community
as a professional--
as a profession-- we
haven't done that yet.
And it's really-- it's overdue.
It's past time.
We hope that's something
that will take on.
There is a grant, a
Project Klein, actually.
And that is trying to increase
the working population
of interpreters of color
to do legal work as part
of their professional
development.
You know, working
in courts, you never
think about, like,
OK, well, this
might not be fair for
how I'm representing.
And really thinking about--
it's supposed to be justice.
It's justice within the justice
system, if you think about it.
So it's a double
layer there as it is.
So whether it's dealing
in the justice system,
or whether it's dealing in
the health care environment,
it's time.
It's overdue for sure.
And thank you for
bringing that up.
- Also, if I could
comment on that.
As far as manipulating the
results, if I could say,
as a black hearing
individual who's
speaking to an audience of
white or Caucasian individuals,
they would prefer to have
a white male interpreter.
Because in that way,
there's a relatability
And see that common
ground, which
then triggers an allyship, which
then triggers active listening.
So then you have
a black audience,
or having that opportunity
to have a person of color
in the audience, and then
having that same demographic
represented by the interpreter.
So again, it does depend on
the result, and the objective,
and what you're looking for.
So that would
impact the judgment
in the decision of whether you
were getting a person of color,
or a Caucasian, a male, or
female identifying interpreter.
- I would add that
people like Jackie
are very conscientious of that
and the choice might sometimes
be, well, I'd prefer to
have another person do it,
but if it means there's going
to be no interpreter present,
I'll take the job.
Yeah.
- Next question.
- Yes.
Go ahead.
- Thank all of you.
This is so wonderful.
All of you.
My question is about
getting older and using ASL.
And I'm so impressed with
the physical vitality,
the manual dexterity this
beautiful language asks of you.
But I'm trying to
imagine my mother who
has arthritis doing this.
And so, it's sort of
me thinking about,
what happens as you get older?
Perhaps you lose a partner
who is also your interpreter?
And also curious, do you lose
words the same way that I'm
starting to lose words.
You know, you're
reaching for them.
I'm curious about the
process of aging with ASL.
- As I mentioned, those
five fundamental parameters,
you can't live without those.
So, you can't do it if you
don't have the hand shape.
You can't convey the language.
But, you have those
four other parameters.
Would you be able to use
those to convey something?
If you do have
movement, you could
recognize there is movement.
But without the
hand shape, it then
indicates something different.
So trying to adjust.
As an example, my
grandfather is deaf.
And he signs very low, like
this, in the signing space.
And I'm trying to
understand him.
I'm like, raise your hands up.
[LAUGHTER]
He's signing so
low in that space.
But over time, I've
gotten used to him
and his mannerisms, his
use of space, location,
and I know what he's indicating.
Sometimes there's some
guesswork involved, you know,
and I'm trying to like,
all right, I think
that's what you're saying.
Which would be no
different than you
as you're interacting with
someone else who's hearing
in the spoken language.
So, I guess, trying to
convey that language.
If you have a weakness in
one of those parameters,
the other parts of
those other parameters
can then reinforce that.
- I want to talk about the
practical implications of that
too, working as a
hearing interpreter--
non-deaf interpreter
with aging populations.
Because so many of us have
come into this language
as second language
learners, we miss nuance.
We are never going to be
100% native in what we do.
Right?
And so, fortunately, we
have tandem colleagues
who are deaf themselves.
Language professionals, who
we refer to as Certified Deaf
Interpreters, who are going to
be these language specialists.
Grew up in this world, visually
acquainted to the world.
Just like these
aging individuals
you were mentioning,
who, for the arthritic
hands, who are missing
parameters, or what have you.
They are going to work
with these individuals,
much like Rosa Lee
and her grandfather,
in a way that I, or
any of my colleagues,
will never be able to do.
And so we want to
see more and more
of these deaf professionals,
deaf interpreters.
That field needs to
expand exponentially
to be able to serve the aging
population, especially the baby
boomers in however many years.
- We are over time, so
we will wrap up now.
This is how you clap in ASL.
So, thank you to our panelists,
and we'll be back [INAUDIBLE]..
[MUSIC PLAYING]